it's the size of 14 football pitches and
everyday extracts enough drinking water
from sea water to fill 172 Olympic sized
swimming pools the main thing you get
out of here is huge amount of water that
can supply the needs of two and a half
million people in Israel or like the
city the size of Chicago
Absalom Felber is the CEO of IDE which
built the Sorek desalination plant
without this plant you would not have
been able to finish this summer with
water in the taps at sorex core are
these massive membranes seawater is
forced against them under super high
pressure filtering out the salt but
that's not all these are the
pretreatment pools where the floating
elements as they're politely known are
separated from seawater which then goes
on to the desalination process but it's
also an excellent spot to give you a
real sense of the scale of this enormous
plant as the world's thirst for water
grows desalination plants look set to
become more common in 2013 the global
desalination market was worth six
billion dollars by 2018 it could rise to
15 billion the Sally tech and Israeli
startup based in Boston sees the best
desalination opportunities in industry
and says it's technology is leagues
ahead because we work at much higher
efficiency we waste a lot less water and
generate a lot less influence from the
process we greatly reduced the energy
consumption and increase the reliability
of the process ide says its technology
speaks for itself
perhaps most surprisingly with an alpine
snow maker we wanted originally to
desalinate water through freezing them
it wasn't economical but we were left
with this ability to freeze large
quantity of the water and make snow out
of them
beyond the ski slopes IDE has a number
of projects in the pipeline including
the western hemispheres largest
desalination plant after a decade spent
battling bureaucracy it will finally
start slaking the first of drought-hit
Californians next year and it got kim
bloomberg Sarek israel